and now it's time for bombing reviews
with Chester a bomb tonight's review Sex
in the City
oh this is the greatest movie I've ever
seen in my life
I have never seen so many women in one
spot at one time and I don't mean in the
movie I mean in the movie theater there
were so many women there and I was the
only guy it was kind of scary I felt
very uncomfortable you think having so
many women in one place would be great
but it's not it's like somebody made a
movie about a sale on shoes every other
second is like yeah blah blah but the
movie was good it stars that actress
that every woman thinks it's a sex
symbol but every guy think she's not and
they have fun going shopping talking
about relationships and walking in
straight lines all at the same time so
it looks like Carrie Bradshaw is getting
married I can't believe it someone
actually won her heart and all her
friends are like and then they're like
me to go shopping and talk about
relationships walking street nights but
at the last minute the guy backs out man
they're all the same always afraid of
commitment a woman's heart is like a
vegetable Jules it has to be taken care
of except on certain times of the month
then you don't touch it
you'll stay as far away as humanly
possible other crimes in the movie and
then they start talking and then uh
talking and talking and the big shocker
at the end talking there was so much
talking wait there is one thing that
didn't have talking is when this guy's
give me a gift to his woman and it's not
really his dick in a box
it's a box in his dick that's ingenious
I'm gonna do that when I give a gift to
my girlfriend if I if I have the money
to get a gift or a girlfriend how much
our girlfriends usually everybody tells
me they're free if that's the case how
come I said a heart
one so I don't really remember much
about the movie all I remember is how
much but the women head watching it they
were laughing and crying and talking and
somehow I walked out with Gucci purse
how the hell did I walk out with a Gucci
purse and high-heeled shoes somehow I
went down there with high-heeled shoes
comes are you really possible caddies
don't see this movie it actually turns
you into a woman somehow why do I
suddenly have an urge to watch the
Golden Girls
hmm smells like femininity this is
history folksy change change come on
help a guy out
can I change wait a minute I have a
Gucci purse never mind
I'd love to a pawn shop